- Industry competitive rivalry,
the focus here, is on the
nature and extent of rivalry
between industry players.
How many competitors are
there in the industry,
and how capable are they?
If there are many competitors
who all offer essentially
equal products or services,
then none of them will be
able to charge premium prices.
When many competitors offer
undifferentiated products,
this tends to reduce
industry attractiveness.
Profits fall.
For example, agricultural
products are commodities
and have a hard time earning high margins.
If rivalry of firms in an industry is low
and firms compete in very
disciplined and predictable ways,
then average levels of
profits tend to be higher.
Discipline rivalry can result
from a number of things.
A long history of the same
firms competing with each other
gives them deep
understanding of each other
and how they will likely
respond to things.
Coke and Pepsi understand
each other intimately.
Sometimes an industry has a large firm
that implicitly sets the rules
of the game for everyone.
When firms know their place
and behave intelligently,
profits tend to be higher.
When the firm acts in a way
that requires a
counter-response by other firms,
rivalry intensifies.
When a firm resorts
to price cuts to capture share,
you can generally expect rivals
to aggressively match the price cut.
Sometimes a spiral of destruction occurs.
Industry profit levels will likely fall.
The airline industry is
a good example of this.
When they have unsold seats,
there is a tendency for them
to offer flights at deep discounts.
These price cuts are typically
quickly met by rivals,
destroying industry profitability.
When firms in an industry compete
with different competitive advantages
and with differentiated
products and services,
generally speaking, there
is little direct rivalry.
Firms are competing for customers.
In these industries,
the profits firms will earn
will be directly related
to the quality of their
competitive advantages.
Intensity of rivalry within an industry
is influenced by a number of factors
such as the number of firms.
A large number of firms increases rivalry
because more firms must compete
for the same customers and resources.
The industry growth rate,
slow market growth causes firms
to fight for market share.
When markets are growing rapidly,
firms compete for new customers,
not directly with each other.
The level of fixed
investments made by firms,
when firms have high fixed costs
and when they must
produce near full capacity
in order to break even,
they will tend to compete
aggressively for market share.
This will increase rivalry
and often lead to lower
prices and lower margins.
Low switching costs,
when customers can freely switch
from one product to another,
there is an ongoing battle for customers.
This increases rivalry.
Level of product differentiation,
when products are highly similar,
customers will typically
seek out the lowest price.
On the other hand, if products
are different and branded,
this tends to constrain rivalry.
Exit barriers,
if firms cannot quit the industry
without losing a lot of money,
they will tend to compete
more aggressively.
On the other hand,
if firms can exit and get
most of their money back,
rivalry will be less aggressive.
Diversity among rivals,
when an industry has a mix of new,
innovative firms and traditional firms,
or domestic and global firms,
or firms of very different sizes,
there is a real possibility
that the industry will be unstable.
Firms have difficulty
anticipating how their rivals might act.
Rivalry could quickly become volatile.
The backgrounds, the cultures,
and the philosophies of firms
impact how they will compete,
both in the short term
and in the long term.